well at 603 it's time to turn on the
lights the party is starting
again on the las vegas strip this
morning the last strip
resort still shuttered by the
coronavirus closures is back in business
we're talking about the cromwell it
opens its doors in just a few hours
hector mejia live this morning at
flamingo and las vegas boulevard with
all the details hey hector
taylor john good morning and there it is
right behind me standing like a monster
and it was almost 230 days ago back in
mid-march
a surreal morning as we were reporting
at the same intersection
talking about the first resorts here on
the strip that were closing and at the
time we were hoping it would last a few
weeks but here we are
seven months later and some parts on the
strip here remain closed
all of that is going to change this
morning the last resort still closed is
reopening
the cromwell is owned by caesars
entertainment some will remember it as
the barbary coast or bill's gambling
hall
and like other caesars properties here
on the strip the cromwell will open with
new safety measures and forced
distancing this is one of the smaller
properties with only 188 rooms and a 40
thousand square foot casino
but it's also popular thanks in part to
the rooftop pool and nightclub trays
they might have opened probably weeks
ago along with other resorts but it
spent more than a whole month as
home base for the cbs reality dating
show love island a lot of people have
watched that show
they used the cromwell as a coronavirus
free bubble in august and
september and even though resorts are
open
demand remains low the lvcva says the
number of tourists to las vegas has
steadily increased every month since
june
but september was still just 50 percent
of what it was
last year and after today the entire
strip is back open but off the strip the
palms and the rio remain
without a reopening date in sight as far
as the crime roll again they reopened
their doors at 10 o'clock this morning
and you can bet we'll be there to see
them
reopen those stores and turn those slot
machines back on reporting live from the
las vegas strip hector mejia
8 news now back to you